so there's a bunch of women this game is
just nonsense okay this game is just
pure nonsense I would kill Gemini what's
up guys welcome back to the couch even
though we're not on a couch today I'm
your host Steve joined by tomorrow
saying hello we're playing The Binding
of Isaac after birth plus the baby game
the baby game the really creepy baby
game which like I am one of the very few
people that's been extremely excited
about in this office at least yeah yeah
everyone's been like what does weird
game talk about this he was talking
about October do we need to call hey cha
know what's happening here you keep
getting excited about October but you
played a little bit of Isaac yeah yeah I
played hundreds of hours of Isaac so I
was super hyped for after birth plus so
we're gonna do today we've got brand new
saves so we've only got to go as far as
killing mom which is something I never
thought I'd say on gamespot you're gonna
be my baby again like this say that role
play baby and we'll get to play the new
character apollyon I'll go through his
backstory
this is the law I need his law ok
apollyon he's new character Sam Jenna
join me you want to be my dude I want to
be the girl who's got a magnet on his
face you haven't unlocked him that's way
better huh we got gold man yeah okay so
this is after with plus new character
apollyon now we're in this I'm room I
explain what his space where item does
not so what that's a first luck foot be
known to be lucky
yeah like well lucky rabbit's foot ah
you just got a sniper this spiders so
polygons active I am
it's called void if you it consumes
other items if you consume another
active item you gain that items ability
so you could have like two or three and
your void will have all these different
active items available if you consume a
passive item you just gain a random
stack but look foot is actually quite
good so I'm gonna take like so well it's
black for dude give me a large chance of
just just lucky of being cool so a
higher level gives you a higher chance
of drops if you've got special tier
effects it'll give you a higher chance
of that happening tier effect yeah so
like if you've got a little window tier
effects
my I killed someone spot this floor a
little bit just to see if we get key for
next rule if you got like freezing tears
ah I was not cool
yeah our speed isn't great which is code
name sloth if you want to kill the
silkworms
I'll kill sloth all right cool guys
these silkworms so it's gonna restart
you're not doing very well right now way
I join me baby don't go over that this
is didn't mean to panic you understand
anything
oh yeah let's go look at space troll ban
he's well pleased with myself
so these grey dues these are new enemy
in afterbirth plus they don't do damage
to you but they push you into other
enemies ah super annoying baby that's
that's something a bit more gross this
is ecoli i mean that was a dozen bad
choice of item to take because what
happens is if you bump into an enemy it
turns them into poo not a big fun which
which i mean if you've got a strong
character with a lot of health or has
some form invincibility it's a great
item but I have one health so I really
don't be touching any enemies playing
this on co-op this one makes it harder
well for this Geiger does at least if
you play as like Isaac who's got a bit
more stack yeah it's not so bad
what's up Allianz back story sick nah
that's actually knows well the parade
IDI a lot of that's like a lot of
biblical Oh God that's that's your baby
special ability some babies have special
abilities and yours is to randomly put
bombs down my baby yeah cuz your was you
you had the troll bomb baby
just pick a new baby
no draw but maybe there's no way you
can't have that baby that's a gold one
so just go just go random but it goes
question mark will give you a random one
I don't know what craze he's got like a
degenerate jaw so I actually didn't know
that that was your baby's ability you
know I never knew either so I think
you've just got a random chance of
spawning troll bombs at the end of each
floor which is what this key jockey for
those who weren't aware that was a key
okay helps you unlock things it doesn't
mean the great start to run but no we
can just blame Aaron Jesus for bad items
there's a big flow of masters basement
well like is the strategy where you can
I can give you your health back yeah in
danger it's like bubbling up in Mario
when you're about to die just like yours
is great I'm definite echinus proper
range mega tears Wow
your eyes what one of the things I love
bhai is ik is is the item synergies cuz
there's some up sometimes be like I
shouldn't take this item because it'll
make me worse even if it's really
powerful item if you get you know four
or five amazing items they start working
together in really interesting ways what
why is this doing my weird loop-de-loops
cuz I picked up the trinket rainbow worm
so there's a bunch of where my this game
is just nonsense okay this game is just
pure nonsense overkill Gemini I've
picked up really I didn't go but so my I
start so you give my health back my poop
crystals are now +10 I mean after that
Plus now allows mods you could make that
if you know it's a program I'm back baby
no I'm not back you're too low on health
for me to come back yeah you take half a
part and I can't afford to not make that
guy he's the human this is bro you
through my evening body went on me okay
can rejoin now just for the sake of
using the item I'm gonna eat that one I
don't know I don't know what you are now
you're some kind of animal ooh Master
Chief is that way yeah is that a helmet
was a hair that's helmet to helmet and
what does it
Kyle McGregor come with Kruger sa
Krieger Krieger I'm gonna drop this
trinket because it's the worst
stupidest thing um do you want how you
look it's a way that's got spikes on it
is that right yeah don't gun spikes what
is that
actually I can't even get hose tap so
how does that makes you immune to
explosions your eyes are freaking me out
yeah that's what prep toasters does to
you man like a bunch of bunch of items
this gamer named after like diseases
[ __ ] and some of it is just like already
good
I wanna try and go eat post hat what is
that stat get a shot it's like a
phallic-shaped I know you disappear and
then vanished I mean I wouldn't put it
past this game I just got that hit I can
lop out with much lower chance to do a
devil but I don't know bloody hell if
anyway so I imagine a lot of people
watching I can be like what the hell I
think this is look at this game is
popular enough that people will know
what we're doing half scam is real it's
not it really well even if you don't
know like the niche parts the game I
like the highbrow parts again really
like it's not yeah it's basically just a
weird-looking schmuck
I want a bomb I wanna keep right Raph
stay away from his bombs is it it's
basically Bomberman but he will drop the
bomb Raley's he should
a bomb item Oh big fan of that guitar
and guitar a bit there I'm gonna not eat
Oh God move I didn't know that had
happened for you as well Oh
the bombs look too similar no one's just
slightly difference right there might be
some hell somewhere 9 that oh my brain
was like collective pick it up eat that
that gave me luck and a little bit -
Ranger when you put the foot I love
what's going on oh yeah foot was last
run for its rip maybe just tinted rug
okay yeah you should be able to come
back you've got the tins apartment what
don't be the trial man again are you
gonna be skele baby
monstro throw like we shouldn't take get
hit against Montreux if we are true but
his MLG games and his his weird shot
holes that he keeps firing out come out
a weird hoax yeah that's quite fusing by
why is he firing out exactly I don't
know blood or see I don't know we're
firing tears other enemies just fire
like vomit or bombs which is delicious
shots man don't question because shot
shots oh I think yeah see jay-z days you
feel crazy lovely plethora see did you
feel crazy crazy
DJ's have made you mental it just has
given us a lot of spare hearts which is
ideal
are they was okay life well we can't
refill spare hearts copies Carla yeah
over you spider
I'll take up his collar gives us a
chance of respawning if you die but if
you get three guppy items you turn into
a dead cat copy items yeah guppy
so now where am i hey what's going on
the name of a dead cat this is the most
video gaming video game I've ever played
but as this guppy means something I
don't understand Thanks
the sound copy is the name of ed
McMillan's cap and in Isaac Isaac's cat
is called guppy and it dies and if you
find pieces of him you become the cat
and lion flies this is why my mom taught
me stop playing video games like this
I fly flyweight flyweight these bats
chasers down
bogus [ __ ] you can come back yeah baby
do we want bum friend I don't think we
want Bob hello oh it's a bum friend bomb
prone bum friend he's a bum he picks up
he picks up coins around the level and
he'll give you consumable drops but what
is the name all about them cuz he's a
bum he wants pennies it's bomb that kind
of bomb yeah and not a blood it's like a
flowing ass just sucking our pennies
okay so we got damage we've got good
damage out actually thank you that's
really good damage okay mate what's
going on there he's a shopkeeper he's
dead why is he keeping a shop then just
move on that there people need cash do
you much hopefully hopefully we can just
avoid that massive room you're a massive
room don't shame me from my voice
whatever people can see all my Isaac
friends okay so we can avoid that big
room
I'm not I'm the on board without
squirting we're gonna kill kill this
boss by turning it's pac-man
what's happening to the music I wasn't
able to even pac-man is chariot don't
get hit I'm gonna vanish wave got little
help yeah I just wanna just wanna watch
Sean I want to monitor his patents for a
second instead is that I was checking
his pants
we've got moldy bread right I'm gonna
high level Isaac stuff now that's a HP
upgrade it's one of the new ones that
deal the devil could be a little planet
oh the guppy dream might be real that's
Guppies head so I'm gonna do I'm gonna
pick up I can spawn flies with it now
the game has registered that I've got
two guppy items and then I'm gonna eat
it for stats and then I'm gonna take
this bread get some HP go down to next
roll high level Isaac's trance that was
what's happening you can rejoin now just
trust me right now I'm doing to the hard
half boom blackouts
oh [ __ ] I'm like a what happened and
like the [ __ ] Superman Superman he's
gone through some tough times
oh god oh damn the buns alright you just
you just stay there okay
yeah you can float behind them like a
hit yeah I can't interact with anything
around me
no you just flow about shoot stuff it is
a good a parcel at least the tears are
good and powerful and powerful tears
Wow bloody case - okay so we're like
two-thirds the way through the through
the run I think money money money money
I just donate a penny donate my I've
done anything my patreon Marcel Ivan
yeah my feet its patreon we haven't
actually found any really gross items
you'll meet a fight I go I got she found
health up
let's keep good looking out who gets the
arcade ceases all right easel oh you
want to fly great we can come back and
donate house later if you want to I was
home hoping to find some of the new ions
from after worth plus because there are
some crazy items you've only had that
one of the only new one we've had so far
is moldy bread great know down I'm room
oh it's those peanuts enemies again one
of the one of my favorite things were
Isaac is because the game never really
tells you exclusively what each enemy is
called yeah come over this does
something take it it's about God / oh
gods flash I think this is a new one I
do though okay I think your rings
enemies yeah shrinks enemies stop Kenny
and by leeches just the old garden are
you hit by one but yeah well as I say
flesh shrinks enemies yeah
don't passionate because like the game
doesn't really like say from the
outgoing hey there's enemies call this
this enemies built this people just have
invented their own names frenemies I
don't know this is got caught it's just
the shopkeeper I'm gonna say this does
poker go go I don't know what it does
hopefully we'll find out
Penina I bet you'll do be something like
catching an immune feel cataloging
enemies well there is there isn't that
item called
at school you're gonna have to come to
the left of me alright just taking a leg
me into a trap I mean I've been tricked
[ __ ] I was like look at me I know the
enemy pans I can avoid it firm but there
is there is a space for item in
afterbirth that has people to eat to
capture enemies and you can throw them
other enemies you just wasted health now
well I gotta say much I got hit twice in
this we've got a 50/50 shot a deal with
the angel devil angel 5 no sin who
friends yeah devil no chubby as a peer
in the basement
no chubby is a basement I'm gonna take
binky
it gives me spare heart oh we got a
place get who's Bozak
Kazak baby tam ready got two more floors
to go we got this all right we got this
dank can oh yes on a switch why'd you
keep giving me up well don't don't just
appear in this room okay with it I'm
back
it keeps giving me that one that turns
into a finger there we go yeah it's back
of me
you've got me baby I keep movin keep
movin keep movin keep movin don't stop
movin what cuz I think I did have the
faculty all the time to tell you that
there's good of your hands coming down
it hunts in hindsight I should have
warned you even like watch the shadows
fudge
I can't pick up items as well that sucks
yeah I'd really like the ability to fly
I can fly but can't trust you I don't so
this is Ouija board it gives you
spectral tears tears that can go through
things I don't want it
so I'm gonna eat it and gain damage
about oh so spawn flies because I a cup
his head again like all these all these
phrases taken out of context is just
don't get sucked into that keep moving
keep moving
watch the shadows the shadows are very
soul
yeah is a to sometimes those dreams will
have like five a charmed fat bat appears
oh that's what poket thing does your
enemy
offering food yeah cuz it's charmed it
sits on a side that's really cool I've
noticed that but that must have been
what they utter any was and we keep it
oh this is my favorite a chance pooter
appears boat sir as well okay this is
squad for building a squad squad goes oh
my god I'm very light house it's
financially no poopoo please please
please please I need you to get out
leave
so gulping scholar gives you a 50/50
shot of respawning every time you die so
I think it's 5050 so we got real lucky
there as bad play on my part though go
and charm flat back so I'm gonna try and
get some HP and then you can come back
not that bad please
did you think it was enemy yeah I hate
this is my life why is that enemy
already on your case
my fat bad please kill kill the last
Pony oh I don't know if that's what the
enemy is called why don't the skeleton
why would you call a puta fly a puta
please kill dead Larry health Oh help
oh the stuff over there no I might rub
that back no all my Isaac Fuu now health
scumbag have her I hate zombies box in
you go him on the back yeah
stone on the front it's like a mullet
fire in the back business up front he
suddenly became worried
is there tinted rock in here bomb fly
kill that an apple it's an apple it's
like a cyst oh come on the Sun yes the
Sun God heals all right all right please
let me meet come on come on straight to
one straight to is a little tough for
the monstre one okay so that in case the
name didn't give it away
I just gave me you just covered again
immediately raised and straight away
yeah if you if you stay on it some
x-axis if it'll blood barrage lazy you
what you're saying running on like if
you if you're on to the left or right if
you're him he won't lazy you sure you
die you stay in the ether let Papa Papa
apollyon Papa bless you this father
bless because there's modding support in
after birth now I'm wondering how long
it's gonna be until like the fake nation
memes and stuff get mother did oh yeah
probably already happened in fact I can
confirm you released one yesterday
oh you learn Lua hey let's program just
for that oh okay no from war combat in
here this is a new item it's called I
don't know but it lets you hold two
trinkets cool thanks for that great pill
great dance next floor I think next
floor is our last floor so it's I've got
a throne or walk your way got Mohawk
yeah check out my Ogden tell me no
that's that's your third eye you got you
got a psychic tear very careful lasers
oh my god I walk into the laser careful
me laser way to see your birthday what's
going on Oh baby's first Isaac kill the
boney ah what you like combo'd me you
come with me
this is on easy mode
well not easier there's no Isaac he's
neither cool to monstros just in a room
why not right as long as that will
always over there and steal your help
especially if I'm near death or
something like surprise man you did you
I think you're just coming back as like
developers of the game yeah we should
just random dudes or beards
kill him for me oh good if she knows go
on I got it see those get closer there
you go
thanks flat thanks 5 in my back I read
all about I forgot because when I knew
save all the shops a hot garbage the
battery mmm refills your spacebar am but
it's already full so we good how do I
get this weekend no no there is a golden
if you shoot the golden poo you get you
get coins oh my god see I keep because
they're so small because of your God's
flesh and also my character is really
small and I keep forgetting that I
basically can float anyway guys I am
trash right you have to stay back
because I'm bad at games
please be good the moon
I mean maybe hey you guys another golden
boot for you yeah the moon I didn't I
didn't get that cuz I hope it comes
through the left channel the earphone
but you I'm taking it you just got the
air voiceover go get the moon there's a
double key room over there
which might be good I heard donkey but
I'm one up for that we could reroll our
entire run oh my god don't die don't die
don't die
I am your first ghost baby is trash I am
so imma eat that I'm a dead though I am
oh come on absolutely no I've still got
a little go get a little bit more health
before we can cuz the final boss is
coming up I hate everything about this
room is ghosts ghosts hey ghosts and
this white skeleton dude you will only
disappear once everyone else is dead
really last chance
where hopefully we can refill our health
before we fight the boss because don't
you keep off my man ticket puff don't
fire blood lasers my pokemons even
watching gavest oh man
four times you just like combine
something weird both one there
don't push means the creep that's what
she said
don't push me to the creek then you hate
it when you're at the club and someone
pushes you the group I'll see people out
there
I mentioned this tinted rock run oh [ __ ]
off host single spirit up is it worth it
it's gonna be clutch I mean this is the
last floor so I'm inclined to say yes
I just really won this game is we'd be
like hypnotic yeah man like I used to I
used to go home and play a run a night
cuz it's it's something I just zone out
- and it was mildly therapeutic oh cool
then cudapah for anything he's firing
lasers again a frowning charmed gaper
has appeared the hell's just call me
weak I know that why my rap album I want
this guy to stay alive he's really
powerful goddess so weird okay I don't
know how you're shooting every room
though look ah he's the best this
Pokemon go I am it's legit man let's
work slow zoom on that as it opens mr.
giant bomb alright
wait fits are open then
I'll try and do it so I do see if I
remember look at that
like back it's got a booty does it have
a booty though I got one bomb which I'm
gonna use to maybe find that laser carry
through into different rooms okay do you
wanna come and help me find mum let me
say yes all right if you die just stay
there I'll assume the Monster Hunter
grip so like in once I land I hope you
control the comb about that guy's bad
luck though you have to chase someone
else yeah just just go random and get
like a doll I did okay train Frank and
don't mind if I'm about to get hit all
okay so if you've never fought mum
before each four walls will have
something spawning on it and it'll also
be a massive foot coming down okay so
once you're dead stay dead and I'll try
mother mother please oh my god that the
laser dude just tore mum up again never
thought I'd say things like this the
crying babies point me off Isaac if you
can land another prinstone shot
Veronica Isaac his mother
he's mashing my fat leg rekt who carried
by the queue mothers in the games mom
was trying to kill him and then God
through by blood yay no no no gonna step
mother is back alright well we managed
it how's it easier on you oh we get to
go to the bloom now fancy fancy Jenny no
not really no well thanks everyone for
joining us if you enjoyed that video
make sure you hit that like button and
subscribe for more
don't play this weird ass game it's
really good it's bad for you I mean it's
go to church be don't say his games Joe
so giggles yeah show you're a local
vicar yeah well they cool breeze father
priest this game is changing in the 20
minutes you've changed yeah all right
well thanks for watching either way
we'll see you next time
[Music]